hello and good evening this is Sky News
at nine o'clock live from Belfast your
headlines
make sure the Irish records and the
Windsor agreements stay in place keep
the peace
the message from U.S President Joe Biden
as he heads to Northern Ireland 25 years
after the signing of the Good Friday
agreement
his visit comes at a time of heightened
security after police in Derry
Londonderry discover four suspected pipe
bombs in the cemetery
tonight's other news this hour as the
junior doctor strike puts the NHS under
more pressure ministers accuse them of
putting patient safety at risk
facing Kentucky revealed the gunman who
killed five colleagues at a bank in
Louisville bought his weapon legally a
week ago
the boss of Britain's biggest business
group The CBI is sacked over misconduct
allegations its board says have been
serious failings
and the S P's finances under the
spotlight again as the party's new
leader reveals Auditors quit lost Autumn
and he's only just found out
[Music]
hello and good evening from Belfast
where we are expecting President Joe
Biden to arrive at Belfast International
Airport within the next 30 minutes or so
he's coming here to Mark and celebrate
the 25th anniversary of the Good Friday
agreement an agreement that largely
brought an end to three decades of
political violence you'll spend time on
both sides of the Border during the next
four days and tomorrow he's going to
make a speech here at Ulster University
now earlier today police discovered four
suspected pipe bombs in a cemetery near
Derry Londonderry close to an area where
petrol bombs are thrown at police
vehicles yesterday it's just a reminder
of the tense security situation here at
this sensitive time now though we are
waiting for the presidents to fly into
Belfast International where he's going
to be greeted by prime minister Rishi
sunat for a handshake now before he left
the United States Mr Biden said that his
top priority was to make sure the Irish
records and the Windsor agreement stay
in place
a senior Island correspondent David
Blevins reports
the well-worn path from the White House
four of the last five presidents have
visited Northern Ireland each pledging
America's help in preserving peace
got the script sir make sure the Irish
Accords and the Windsor agreements stay
in place and keep the peace
Joe Biden welcomed the UK's deal with
the EU on post-brexit trading
arrangements and his presence could help
restore power sharing according to the
first Minister designate I think it's
hugely important given the year that
we're in you know because the Americans
have such skin in the game if you like
they were part of bringing about the
Good Friday agreement so I think to come
this year is hugely significant
particularly given that they're very
much focused on the next 25 years
they're focused on economic investment
here so they really want to look towards
the future as do we
Bill Clinton was the first U.S president
to make the trip to Belfast marking the
terrorist ceasefires at Christmas 1995.
Hillary and I thank you from the bottom
of our hearts for making us feel so very
very welcome in Belfast and Northern
Ireland
and they've just kept coming since
America came to express its support for
the Good Friday agreement at every
opportunity and to those who choose the
path of peace I promise you the United
States of America
will support you
but not everyone has chosen that path
it's still a fragile pace and there's a
massive Security operation in place the
threat level in Northern Ireland has
risen from substantial to severe meaning
a terrorist attack is deemed highly
likely
the threat isn't directed against the
president himself but his visit takes
place against a backdrop of dissident
Republicans targeting police and
there'll be a significant increase in
the number of them deployed
operationally while he's in Northern
Ireland
each key location will have been
thoroughly searched and locked down says
Jim gamble a former assistant chief
Constable at the end of the day you
don't need to be particularly
sophisticated to disrupt an event like
this it's as cheap as a phone call so
you've got to be confident that if an
anonymous threat comes in and that the
security precautions that you've put in
place are sufficiently tight that you
can say that's not possible
he'll spend most of the week in the
Republic of Ireland the ties Run Deep
between the two Nations 40 million
Americans claiming Irish descent but
this is personal for Joe Biden he'll
revisit his ancestral Homeland live and
Mayo where he's guaranteed kid Miller
falcher a hundred thousand welcomes
all right let me just run you through in
a bit more detail the president's
schedule as you understand it from this
evening now he's going to land in about
20 minutes or so at Belfast
International in Air Force One where
it's going to be met by the Prime
Minister Rishi sunak they're going to
hold a bilateral meeting tomorrow
morning then the president is due to
meet the political leaders from the five
main parties here in Northern Ireland
before he delivers a keynote speech here
at Ulster University's new Belfast
campus now once he leaves Belfast
tomorrow he's going to travel onto the
Republic of Ireland for a number of
engagements in County louth where as
David said in his report there he has
ancestral Roots he'll be visiting
carlingford Castle before spending the
night in Dublin now on Thursday he is
expected to meet the Irish President
Michael D Higgins and the Prime Minister
Leo varadka and address the Irish
Parliament as well as attend a banquet
at Dublin castle in the evening now his
trip's going to conclude on Friday with
the visits to County mayor where he has
more family and he'll make a public
speech at the Cathedral in Ballina
well our senior Island correspondent
David Blevins is here with me now and
David we're seeing there are more police
arriving here ahead of Biden's speech a
big Security operation in force yes and
we think that Security operation will
swing up to a higher level even within
the next R this area going into lockdown
in preparation for the President coming
to make that address at the University
tomorrow I think the fact that he's not
going to Parliament buildings at
Stormont where there is no power sharing
government at the moment but coming here
is an indication perhaps that he thinks
it's up to the Next Generation to make
the hopes of the Good Friday agreement a
reality but there is a very tense
security situation we know that the
Threat Level was raised last month the
MI5 will have made that decision
separate from any government involvement
on the basis of the current intelligence
and that's because they're concerned the
dissident Republicans still pursuing the
objective of Irish Unity by violent
means could continue their efforts to
attack police officers as we saw with
the attempted murder of a senior officer
last month in County Tyrone there will
also be concerns about loyalist
paramilitaries of course you remain
active as well and they're very angry
about the brexit Border in the Irish sea
so a number of officers who would
normally be at on desk duties have been
deployed operationally under the streets
and of course that makes them a Target
and we've also been informed that 300
police officers have been drafted in
from Great Britain to lend their support
as well yeah there is a large security
presence in four statement as you say
this area is about to go into lockdown
let's just talk about Biden's
involvement in all of this we're
expecting him as we say in the next
10-15 minutes or so he's going to come
here with a message of Hope a message of
trying to build consensus you've got to
be careful exactly how he tries to
deliver that message yes and not least
because Joe Biden has seen as a very
Irish American president so there's a
risk of him antagonizing the unionists
rather than encouraging them to become
part of the power sharing government
again he's been very open about the fact
that he has ancestral rooting the
Republic of Ireland he has made jokes in
the past clearly indicating that perhaps
his view is that there should be Irish
Unity rather than Northern Ireland
remaining part of the United Kingdom but
it does of course because under the Good
Friday agreement the key principle of
consent is that it will remain part of
the United Kingdom until the majority
here vote otherwise and that's why prime
minister Rishi sunak is at Belfast
International Airport this evening to
welcome him because he is going to very
briefly be in one corner of the United
Kingdom on this visit but it's primarily
about a visit to Ireland he's going to
Dublin very quickly tomorrow where he
will as you say meet with the president
meet with the teacher Kelly of Radko the
Prime Minister and address a joint
session of the upper and lower Houses of
Parliament that's really the focus yeah
and as we're talking David you can see
the time act there at Belfast
International the stairs are already
there prepared early for Air Force One
to be touching down it's expected about
20 past and you and you say once it
lands there's a quite a long taxi to get
to that point is there yeah some people
may wonder why Air Force One is heading
to Belfast International Airport which
is about 30 40 minutes outside of the
city rather than going to the George
best Belfast City Airport just on the
outskirts of the city the answer is very
simple the runway at Georgia best
Belfast City Airport isn't long enough
to accommodate Air Force One that's why
it always goes to what people in
Northern Ireland described as Aldergrove
airport that's its own its old name but
it is the International Airport these
days that's where he will arrive he
departed Washington as you say uh this
afternoon telling reporters that he was
coming here to recommit America to uh
preserving peace in in Northern Ireland
and uh even as we talk about the The
Fragile piece in Northern Ireland we can
hear and we can see that the Security
operation is ramping out ramping up
around us here yeah
far more blue lights than a there were a
little while before so look when he when
he finally gets here and he first of all
sits down with um with Rishi sunak and
they had that bilateral they're going to
be sort of hashing out the the benefits
of the The Windsor framework that has
been put in place to replace the
Northern Ireland protocol and this is
the thing that's meant to bring the
assembly back together and get it
functioning again do you think we should
do that's going to try and advise him
how he wants when he eventually meets
those leaders to discuss that and and
the benefits that he thinks he sees in
it yes I would imagine that he will uh
the Prime Minister put a huge effort
into trying to resolve the difficult to
post exit trading Arrangements which
have caused such a problem
brexit was never really ever compatible
with the Northern Ireland peace process
because it was always going to require a
border somewhere and the Border has been
invisible for the best part of three
decades now between Northern Ireland and
the Republic the the renewed Focus On
the Border has been a significant
political problem and in an effort to
avoid a border on this island again of
course Boris Johnson did what he said no
British prime minister could ever do and
that was establish a trade Border in the
IRC between Great Britain and Northern
Ireland and that's a big problem for
unionists to believe they've now been
cast adrift to some extent they believe
that raises the Constitutional question
of where Northern Ireland's future lies
but it's interesting this afternoon to
hear Joe Biden talk about the Windsor
framework he's clearly very well
informed about recent political
developments about that deal Ricky sunak
has done with the EU to try and resolve
these difficulties and the Prime
Minister must be very disappointed that
the dup are still not content enough to
restore power sharing government that's
what he hoped would happen for the 25th
anniversary and if it had happened I
have no doubt whatsoever that Joe Biden
would not be coming to the new 360
million pound Campus of Ulster
University but would be going to address
the Northern Ireland assembly I think
that's where they all want him to be
addressing with that Empower sharing
executive could get back in away and it
was interesting that you mentioned the
winter framework on his way here
that suggests he's got himself a little
bit abreast of some of the the details
the intricacies of all of this because
you're going to come here big picture
it's consensus we're going to try and
maintain peace there's some real real
sort of nuances that he needs to be
aware of and as you said earlier make
sure he doesn't say the wrong thing that
then antagonizes on one side that could
uh could Scupper it yes and I suppose
what he wants to do is to build on the
work that America has done in the past
in terms of
um the peace process in Northern Ireland
to remember it was way back in 1994 that
Bill Clinton's involvement here helped
pave the way to the provisional Ira
ceasefire when he famously visited that
historic trip back in Christmas 1995
there was a lot of debate about whether
or not he could be seen to publicly
shake the hand of Jerry Adams Then the
shin Fein leader the world's most
recognizable Irish Republican so that
was facilitated not in a not in a in a
formal way but informally when the
president went Walkabout on the Falls
Road Jerry Adams just happened to be
there and we he witnessed the famous
handshake Bill Clinton's Envoy Senator
George Mitchell was the man who then
brokered the Good Friday agreement so
there has been a significant investment
and what we have a political investment
I'm talking about but America's always
been very careful to combine the
political investment with talk about
economic investment and there has been
talk about about that before this trip
has even got underway that there are
there's a deal to be done in some ways
that there can be more inward investment
into into this part of Britain once the
executive gets back underway that in
itself I think is an indication that
they understand the sensitivity that for
some
step too far for America to be
politically involved at a significant
level in the Northern Ireland peace
process so by talking about economic
investment you soften that a little bit
and of course the one thing that just
may encourage politicians to get back
into Stormwind and to restore the person
in government is the suggestion that it
will lead to American Investment and
more jobs here in Northern Ireland
because that's what matters to most
people here yeah absolutely right okay
David plenty more from you throughout
the evening as we awaits the arrival of
President Biden into Belfast
International but of course President
Biden massively proud of his Irish roots
and our U.S correspondent James Matthews
has been getting some more detail on his
background from his home time in the US
Scranton Pennsylvania
a city very American very Irish American
[Music]
years it's counted a quarter of its
population as Irish descendant including
the Scranton boy who made the big stage
somebody in power who's Irish who's very
proud of where he came from even though
maybe not being born in Ireland is a
very cool thing it is such an amazing
thing to be Irish and the president he
seems proud oh yes very proud
a young baseball loving Joe Biden lived
at this Scranton house until he was 10
years old it was the home of his
grandfather Ambrose Finnegan he was told
many times the story of his Irish Roots
it's a story he's clearly never
forgotten
my grandfather Ambrose Finnegan every
time I walk out of his house he'd say
Joey remember the best drop of blood in
his Irish
Joe Biden themed the White House Irish
for Saint Patrick's Day this a president
whose ancestors crossed the Atlantic in
the 19th century the Finnegans of County
louth and the bluitts of County Mayo
behind a green door in Washington we
heard of the Biden contribution
to peace in Northern Ireland Stella
O'Leary is the president's appointee to
the international fund he's a hero as a
Senator Joe Biden helps set up the fund
to promote peaceful coexistence in
Northern Ireland that was an existence
starting from 1986. so it also formed
the foundation of the peace agreement so
it's been a long time and Joe Biden was
in there from the start
this President knows the place and the
process that's long taken one step
forward and two steps back
this week he'll celebrate the progress
he helped to promote
James Matthews Sky News in Scranton
Pennsylvania
all right well let's bring in now Lori
Watkins former policy advisor to
President Obama and Lori good to have
you with us we saw there in James's
piece Biden's hometown of Scranton and
really the way that he shows his his
pride his pride of being Irish I mean
how does that play for him politically
at the moment
do you mean over there or do you mean
here in the U.S how does it play
politically
I mean in the U.S
yes in the U.S I think that the average
American equates or relates to or
Associates is the word I should use the
Irish to hard-working
um tough tough roots tough blood to
working class uh
I think we may have lost the line to
Laurie there which is a shame but
thankfully David Blevins is still here
he knows everything even the length of
the runway at Belfast International so
David I was just putting to Laurie there
the way that a president Byron plays to
his Irish heritage in a U.S context see
give us a thought on that and how you
think that works for him over there uh
40 million people in the United States
claim Irish descent there's about four
and a half million people living on the
island of Ireland so some people would
say what you've got nine times as many
people in America claiming to be Irish
as here in Ireland on this island itself
and that I think tells you why this
matters especially when you're
considering running for a second term in
the white house that's a significant
vote and that's why Joe Biden will be
the actually the eighth U.S president to
come to Ireland he's only the force to
come to Northern Ireland but he will be
the eighth to come to the Republic of
Ireland and they nearly always come
towards the end or in the second half of
their first term so there is clearly an
electoral card at play here in terms of
this visit as well so it is all right
David thank you for that and I think
we've got the line back to Laurie Laura
Watkins I think you can hear us again
now I don't know if you heard what David
was saying just the importance of the
Irish American votes on 40 million Irish
Americans in the US and and
and I'm now told that Laurie has frozen
once again but
without fail thankfully David Blevins
hasn't stepped away even though it's
freezing cold I know you want to go and
sit in the car but David you're still
with me let's move on to a subject that
you're far more comfortable although
it's a fantastic answer about the Irish
Americans we can take you now
two
Belfast International Airport where I am
told President Joe Biden is
landed he has arrived and uh
we are now if you can see there looking
at
what is the presidential
747 Air Force One has arrived in
Northern Ireland President Joe Biden the
fourth U.S president to come to the
north of Ireland uh packed schedule
ahead of him which will begin
once he finishes his taxi in Air Force
One and makes his way there too as you
can see the waiting steps with a
handshake and a meeting with the UK
prime minister Rishi suno so David as we
see that uh Air Force One has now
touched down in Northern Ireland prison
Biden's historic visits to Mark the 25th
anniversary of the Good Friday agreement
begins yes and I think it is just an
indication of the extent to which the
United States has invested so much
political capital in Northern Ireland
and its effort to move from conflict to
a lasting Pace it is 27 years since Air
Force One first landed at Belfast
International Airport transporting but
then President Bill Clinton and first
lady Hillary Clinton who went on of
course to become Secretary of State but
also happens to be right now the
chancellor of Queen's University in
Belfast and the clintons themselves will
be here next week to Mark the 25th
anniversary of the Good Friday agreement
but since then we've had four presidents
in total come here to recommit America
to the preservation of peace and to
express their support for the power
sharing government in Northern Ireland
so it's always a hugely significant
thing to see Air Force One landing in
Northern Ireland a place with a
population of fewer than 2 million
people all and yet we see the leader of
the Flea World coming here on a fairly
regular basis these days yeah and the
City Center as we said earlier is is in
lockdown and once he arrives and and
meets with Rishi sunak he'll get a few
hours rest and then the work begins yeah
so just look at that Entourage preparing
for his uh arrival here in Northern
Ireland I'm told somewhere in the region
of a thousand people have traveled from
the United States as part of that
Entourage Secret Service have been here
for some time they'll have been carrying
out defensive searches across every key
location to ensure that there is no
possibility of the president being in
danger given the increased Terror threat
but as we were explaining earlier Kamali
the threat is not directed against the
president of the United States it is
from dissident Republicans primarily
pursuing Irish Unity still by violent
means and their intent on attacking
police officers and we're going to see a
significant increase in the number of
police officers visibly present on the
streets of Northern Ireland over the
next 24 hours there's been a significant
redeployment not just from officers who
would normally be at their desks in
Northern Ireland but from their
colleagues in Great Britain coming to
offer support as well yeah and as we say
he's going to meet Rishi sunai Quincy uh
gets off uh the presidential Jet and
that's a meeting that not only is
significant to to Northern Ireland but
also the relationship between the US and
the UK right now is key at least because
of the war in Ukraine yes and there's
been a lot of discussion between the
White House and dining State over the
last couple of weeks about exactly how
this is going to play out and it's
because this is the only corner of the
United Kingdom that President Biden is
visiting on this trip and we already
know for example that he will not be
attending the king's correlation in May
so Rishi sunak of course as prime
minister of the United Kingdom will be
the person who greets him at the foot of
the steps when the president steps out
shortly we hope it can take them a
little while to freshen up after the
long journey across the Atlantic but I
can see the welcoming party in the Lord
Lieutenant the Queen's representative
are the king's representative I should
say in Northern Ireland making his way
no to the fifth of the steps so they are
preparing clearly for him to step off
the furniture I guess those steps we
were looking at before with someone else
of course the president brings his own
steps when they arrive somewhere so we
are now awaiting prison Joe Biden to
disembark Air Force One become the
fourth president to arrive here in
Northern Ireland in this part of the UK
for what will be a historic visit he is
um here to commemorate to Mark the 25th
anniversary of the Good Friday agreement
and he really has a packed schedule
ahead of him he will be spending some
time as well speaking to the leaders the
five leaders of the main parties here in
Northern Ireland in an attempt to try
and gain some kind of consensus get
power sharing back in line now
as we continue to watch his picks if you
look closely there in the middle of shot
you can definitely see that is prime
minister Rishi sunak there in the dark
suit awaiting there he is shaking hands
there with the the awaiting dignitaries
and that looks like the presidential
vehicle has pulled up what do they call
that one the Beast the Beast ready for
President Biden to be driven in it and
it's uh about a 30 minute drive yourself
in Belfast International to the city
center and you'll be entering the cordon
and going to a large city center Hotel
yes and when Bill and Hillary Clinton
famously became the first couple from
the White House to visit Northern
Ireland in 1995 they made the courageous
decision to stay in the famous Europa
hotel in the city center it was at that
time the most bombed hotel in Western
Europe the president isn't staying in
the Europa normally they keep these
things under wraps but it's difficult to
do that when you have this scale of a
Security operation we know he's staying
in a hotel in a street parallel to the
Europa that's where he'll make his way
this evening he's not going to get a lot
of sleep he has an early start in the
morning as you say he's going to have a
a brief meeting with the Prime Minister
Rishi sunak he will then come here to
Ulster University to address an audience
of around 400 people we think and to
meet with the five main Party leaders
including the shin Finn first Minister
designate Michelle O'Neill and with
Jeffrey Donaldson the leader of the
democratic unionist who of course is
refusing to bring his party back into
the park sharing Arrangement at Stormont
because of the brexit order in the RFC
now I'm told that meeting with those
leaders is going to be a meet and greet
are you getting a sense they're all
going to meet as a as five on one or
maybe we're shooting that there as well
or they get some little individual sort
of breakout meetings do we think I think
it'll be a very short encounter for each
of them all in one room off to the side
at the moment I'm told by our friends at
the U.S consulate in Belfast that that
meeting will not be on camera that may
change this is a very fluid situation as
you know in terms of the political
sensitivity days but no doubt his
message to them both privately and
publicly would be that it's time to
restore the power sharing government in
Northern Ireland thank you David and
there he is present Joseph R Biden the
46th president of the United States
making his way down the steps to be
greeted from behind that presidential
limo with prime minister Rishi sunak a
salute a warm welcome from the Lord
Lieutenant for County Antrim the king's
representative in that part of Northern
Ireland and all smiles from the Prime
Minister very
looking to welcome the Prime Minister
and as Senator Joe Kennedy there I think
is the new um Northern Ireland
representative from the U.S government
who was here on this visit uh playing a
cure he's going to be staying on I
understand once President Biden does go
back to try and ensure that the U.S
government role in trying to get
consensus back and get power sharing
back at Stormont uh keeps having that
sort of impetus yes at the White House
says over the years had many envoys to
Northern Ireland including Senator
George Mitchell himself who spent four
years here brokering the historic
compromise between the political parties
but isn't it interesting to see Joe
Kennedy appointed as a a an Envoy to
Northern Ireland these days in many ways
we've come full circle yeah if she does
that right because indeed because it was
President John F Kennedy you could
describe as the most Irish American of
all present Wexford in the West on the
east coast of Ireland and made it from
Wexford to the White house in the space
of one generation it's not a bad Journey
well as you as you said David all all
smiles now is the the present it is
finally here as we said the fourth
president to to come to this part of the
United Kingdom a quick chat there with
uh Rishi sunak and as you say David he's
got a packed scheduler ahead of him so
once he's done the sort of the meet and
greet and said the right things and all
the pleasantries will be West off into
the city where I guess the work will
begin on preparing for that speech and
and you say it's going to be a speech to
students to some 400 people I'm told
it's going to be about 25 minutes long I
mean what do you expect that the tone of
it to be
talk to the Next Generation in Northern
Ireland that perhaps suggests that he
isn't so confident that the political
leaders of today are going to manage to
restore the power steering government
and to see the hopes of the Good Friday
agreement become a reality and therefore
he is going to come here and send that
message to a wider audience that it's
time to embrace the hopes of Northern
Ireland um and the hopes that were
established way back on the 10th of
April 1998 on that day when Senator
George Mitchell uttered those famous 19
words I'm pleased to announce that the
two governments and the political
parties of Northern Ireland have reached
agreement it was really a a very
momentous day in Northern Ireland coming
just four years after the terrorist
organizations had declared ceasefires
and it was a it was really a master
stroke in terms of creative ambiguity
because it allowed both unionists and
nationalists to claim that they had
achieved something unionists achieved
the principle of consent that Northern
Ireland will remain part of the United
Kingdom until a majority here vote
otherwise of course we saw prisoners
released early from prisoners part of
the Good Friday agreement and all of the
terrorist organizations pledged to
destroy their weapons so you really
couldn't exaggerate the significance of
that day yeah it was incredible and
being able to give people on both sides
exactly what they wanted to continue to
look at these pictures it does show me
that this is a family affair we can see
Dr Joe Biden there in the foreground and
off to the right of screen there that
looks to me like Hunter Biden the
president's son there I know that the
bidens did travel to Ireland back in
2017 to check out their ancestry in the
genealogy and just to confirm
whereabouts in the Republic they are
from and of course as we said later on
this week they're going to be making a
similar journey to County louth and
County Mayo there's no no doubt
whatsoever that the president is very
proud of his Irish ancestry having
visited as vice president both those
ancestral counties of live and mayo and
you will remember during his election
campaign just how often he quoted The
Poetry of Sheamus Heaney so I think the
president really has a sense of
connection with Irish culture with Irish
heritage and and how many times do we
hear him saying I'm Irish at one stage
we had that significant moment where
someone stepped forward to doorstep him
as we say in the media and they said I'm
from the BBC and he said I'm Irish so he
didn't want to talk to the British
Broadcasting Corporation that's how
Irish two Biden considers himself and
then if you'd be able to say that sort
of thing now but well look we can see
that the delegations are getting into
dilemma into the Beast they're going to
be driving away from Belfast
International having
done the handshakes said their hellos
you know they've just come across the
Atlantic they must be tight and there is
plenty of work ahead for this U.S
delegation here in in Ireland not at
least in Northern Ireland but also once
they get to the Republic to try and
continue to build on that
um 25th anniversary of the Good Friday
agreement and one thought I just want to
get from you David is is this sense of
of President Biden kind of stepping on
uh what has gone before of course such a
huge moment 25 years ago when that
agreement was made Power sharing has
broken down how how much do you think
Biden feels like it is incumbent on him
as a Democrat and as an Irishman to try
and help this thing along a little bit
well America has always been incredibly
staunchly defensive of the Good Friday
agreement not least because they
consider that perhaps President Bill
Clinton's finest moment in terms of
foreign policy achievement and of course
this is another Democratic president in
office now considering a run for a
second term so he wants to demonstrate
that same level of commitment not just
in Ireland but in the Northern Ireland
peace process and that every every time
we've seen a president here it seems to
be at a significant moment Bill Clinton
came because the terrorist ceasefires
had been declared he visited on a number
of occasions not least soon after the
bombing of oma in 1998 this the largest
single atrocity so now we have another
president setting fit on Northern Irish
soil at a time when there is a political
difficulty which has been caused of
course by the consequences of brexit
yeah and which thing the reaction is
going to be from the leaders of those
parties when he meets them tomorrow very
set on either side of this and unwilling
to to compromise I mean voting against
the agreement the dup did in the Commons
just recently
the president comes across the Atlantic
to talk to them what kind of reception
do you think he's going to get well you
heard in my report earlier this this
sorry the sinfian deputy leader Michelle
O'Neill who's the first nationalist to
have been elected to the office of first
Minister designate says this is always
significant because of what she
describes as America's skin in the game
because America has invested so much in
Northern Ireland and she says it's
really important for him to come here to
express this level of support
politically and economically and uh
there we have the Prime Minister also
just about to depart Belfast
International Airport and make his way
to his own hotel overnight where he'll
be doing some preparation for that
important meeting with the U.S president
in the morning Northern Ireland
secretary Chris Heaton Harris as well
who has also got word today I mean it
just sort of reinforces doesn't it you
know power sharing has been broken down
for a couple of years now it's
doesn't seem like it's getting closer to
coming back so these top level
politicians will really want to see if
they can drive it forward a bit and I
guess there's a there was a lot of that
in 197 The Good Friday agreement you had
a new government come in you had a lot
of exhaustion from all those years of
violence that can happen in politics
kind of you can suddenly get like a
little bit of input a little bit of oof
that gives something a push Molly I'm
impressed your eyesight's better than
mine being able to pick out Chris Heaton
Harris in the dark at Belfast
International Airport this evening but
he is a man obviously with a lot of work
to do because of the difficulties that
Stormont as Northern Ireland's secretary
he has effectively had to step in to
govern this place with a small team
around them for a period of time not
that that is a return to the formalities
of direct rule from Westminster we would
have seen before there was a devolved
government in Northern Ireland
there is a problem right now we know the
problem exists because the dup were our
boycotting the power sharing government
over brexit and that means Northern
Ireland does not have a functioning
government right now and that's
something we've seen many times the
collapse of the Northern Ireland
assembly the collapse of the power
sharing executive over the last 25 years
the reason for that and I suppose to
some extent it is the flaw in the Good
Friday agreement
mandatory Coalition requires the largest
unionist party and the largest
nationalist party to agree if there is
to be a power sharing government so the
moment they there's a dispute between
them over anything that government
collapses but that political mechanism
which effectively gives a veto to the
largest unionist party and the largest
nationalist party squeezes out the
middle ground their votes don't seem to
be just as valuable and that's why many
people are calling for a restructuring
of the system because the mechanism the
political mechanism that is the Good
Friday agreement to underscore a fragile
piece here are under pen and fragile
Pace here is also the very thing that
often causes the political paralysis
very well David we continue to look at
these pictures from Belfast
International Airport you can see tarmac
clear the beasts is rolling President
Joe Biden on his way the short drive 30
40 minutes from the outskirts of the
city into the city center where it's
gonna overnight before he begins his
pack schedule to Mark the anniversary of
the 25th signing
of the Good Friday agreement and also
spend time in the Republic of Ireland it
is ancestral homelands in both County
life and County Mayo and we'll be
fitting in a good couple of keynote
speeches
there he is President Biden
making his way
into Belfast City Center
yeah a couple of keynote speeches
weren't here at Ulster University and
also one at the Irish parliament in
Dublin
um well there you have it President Joe
Biden has arrived in Northern IV U.S
president to do so greeted there by
dignitaries including the U.S ambassador
to the UK and of course the Prime
Minister Rishi sunac those two are going
to hold a bilateral meeting tomorrow
it's gonna be longer than this little
chat they had on the tarmac of course
plenty for them to to discuss at least
the war in Ukraine and the Windsor
framework and trying to get power
sharing back up and underway well that's
all from us here in Belfast for me and
David is back to Anna